- What's up everybody.
I'm here with Jane Lynch
and with us via Skype is Matt Bomer,
give it up for him y'all!
All right so
Twitter grows us some deep and
meaningful questions y'all,
don't you feel that?
- [Jane] Oh absolutely.
- [Kelly] Luckily Jane, Matt and I
are here to field those questions for you
in another round of
Kelly's Ultimate Twitter Questionnaire
♪ It's Kelly's Ultimate
Twitter Questionnaire. ♪
You better get it with your little bop.
Okay. Here's what we do y'all,
I'll read some of the most
pressing questions we found
on Twitter recently,
super pressing.
Then Jane, Matt, and I will help out
by giving flawless opinions,
solutions, and answers to those questions.
Kind of like our version of Dear Abby.
Our first on today's
Twitter questionnaire comes
from @thatericalper who asks,
you are given 10 seconds to talk
to your dog or cat, and
they understand you.
What do you say?
- I say relax, I'm always
going to be with you.
You don't have to bite the other dog.
You don't have to bite the dog Walker.
All you have to do is know that I love you
and I will always be with you.
Chill the (beep) out man.
(laughing)
- Calm down!
Um Matt, what about you?
- I have two dogs.
I would say Stella, you
are perfect in every way,
just please stop pooping on the rug.
That's all I ask of you.
Lucky our boy dog, who
thinks that every time I'm
in a swimming pool,
something is wrong with me.
So he tries to jump into the
pool and save me by swimming.
On top of my head.
I would alleviate him
of that responsibility.
- Oh my god,
I love that he thinks that's
saving you by drowning you.
Um I think I would just ask Henry,
Henry is a great dog, he
doesn't do anything wrong.
- [Jane] That's perfect.
- [Kelly] Yeah, he's pretty perfect.
- [Jane] I love it.
- [Kelly] Yeah so I think I'd just ask him
what the hell do you want to do today?
- Yeah, there you go.
- [Kelly] Yeah cause I always
guess, and I'm probably wrong.
So what do you want to do?
And then I'd do it, yeah.
I wish you, I wish that was possible.
- [Jane] Yeah me too.
- Okay well this one is
from our house seats.
It's our spotlight singer who goes
by the Twitter name of @macykrewmusic.
So Macy, what did you ask?
- [Macy] All right y'all so
if you could only eat one
breakfast cereal for the rest
of your life, which would you choose?
But there's also a twist,
you can't add any fruit or sugar.
- Wow, Matt, you want to go first?
- No brainer, Lucky Charms all day long.
(laughing)
No fruit needed,
- [Kelly] (inaudible)
- The marshmallows I like.
Also give me my little crunch.
It's got everything I need.
- [Kelly] Oat crunch.
(laughing)
- Mine would be Captain Crunch.
As you know, I love peanut butter and
Captain Crunch has peanut butter
and it's sugary and it's
delicious, and it's crunchy.
- [Kelly] I don't eat cereal.
It's not my favorite thing.
But when I was a kid, my
favorite was Lucky Charms.
So I'm going go with Lucky Charms,
my favorite but what I'd do is
I'd take out all the marshmallows
and piss off everyone in my family.
(laughing)
And I'd just take all the
marshmallows for the thing.
And then, so then people
would just have those
you know, crunchy oats.
(laughing)
Yeah, everyone didn't like me.
I love, I'm like elf,
like anything was sugar,
I'm like him.
(laughing)
All right, next one.
This is from who @jportnay who,
what's the one TV series
you'd end differently,
and how would you do it?
Oh!
Matt, how about you?
A TV series that you
could change the ending.
- Wow, that's a really tall order.
Trying to think of some of the things
I've binged over the course.
- [Kelly] I feel pressure
to be cool with my answer.
- [Matt] Maybe Game of Thrones?
- [Kelly] Okay would you?
- [Jane] Yeah what would you do?
- I mean, I liked the ending
but there were just so many
different endings I had in mind.
I would definitely keep Daenerys alive.
- Mhmm, I wouldn't have had her um
turn so dark.
I would've kept her, yeah yeah.
And where she gets together
with John, yeah, exactly.
John White Snow,
- [Kelly] John Snow.
But you, snow is white you're close.
- [Jane] Snow blabs.
(laughing)
- Would that be yours?
- Well, I like that.
I'm glad he said that because
of that, he can say it.
And I agree now I'll tell you mine.
On MASH I would like to have
McClain Stevenson's
character not have died
and McLean Stevenson himself not have died
and come back and say
Oh, he was just lost in a
plane crash and he's fine.
Cause I loved that guy, I loved the actor.
I loved his character and
he died in the middle of it.
- MASH, what a good one.
- [Jane] Yeah.
- Wow, that was on forever.
- [Jane] It was and what
a great show that was.
- [Kelly] That main, (vocalizes tune)
I can always hear the theme song.
- Suicide is dangerous,
or painless, suicide is painless.
- It was so good.
Um I don't know if I'd really change
an ending other than
the fact that it ended.
I was so heartbroken
when Friends ended.
- [Jane] Yeah.
(laughing)
- I was, I was the perfect age of like,
that was the first time I really
got into a show like that.
And we literally, every Thursday
night met at my friend's.
It was like a thing.
It was like something
bigger than, than the show.
But anyway, I think I would
just would change the fact
that it ended.
So, that sucks.
- [Jane] I would too, and it's on pause.
You know, they stay that age
for the, for the rest of time.
- [Kelly] For the rest of time.
No, I actually want to
see the aged version too.
- That would be funny too.
Yeah, no one,
no one's in a relationship.
- [Kelly] And I want Joey to
still be that guy, but he's
like the older dude that
is like, it's not the same.
- [Jane] No it's not
working for him anymore.
I love it.
- Kelly] It would be, I have great ideas.